I'm gonna join the the daily rapid arena
and I was thinking I would do something
a bit different have a themed stream of
only playing gambits so I think what
I'll do is for one minute have a notepad
document I'm just gonna write down as
many gambits as I can think of Alexa set
a timer for one minute okay Kings gambit
means gambits not sure if there's
apostrophes there Blackmar Deemer Evans
gambit Bank oh okay I don't have to
write down ganda just Banco Budapest
what else
why am i blinking a molar attack you
sack upon laughing Yandex guess this
gambits in the name I should write it
down
Neiman hmm Knight of 3g5 whatever that's
called if you're just joining help me
think of gambits boat s camp it's some
gamuts of Danish Danish goring scotch uh
what else
why am i blinking there's so many gap of
Smith Mora okay Alexa shut up all right
I have a list I'll probably add to this
not sure how you classify the bond cloud
gambits Oh Halloween okay I'll be a nice
addition Oh stafford of course okay
okay I have my list I will keep it on
another side maybe I'll add to it over
time but I'm gonna join the tournaments
GM jlh that's that's hammer boat s
gambit maybe we'll make an appearance
but to play a boat s gambit it has to be
unintentional rights or it just has to
be questionable compensation I'll see
what I can I can make out of the game
it's called a story how's it going
things hammer for the resub loft unit
yeah so here's a list just waiting for a
game to start oh there's a the France
Candace to play against of birds opening
ok I'm black let's see what to do here
efore hmm oh there's uh what do they
call it 'the icelandic is it icelandic
Cabot's let's just start with you 5 it
should be 4 ok we have a keen scabbit
and now we're gonna have a fall Kabir
counter gambit this is good start before
this is a line that I sometimes enjoy
playing g3 I've never seen before
when was the g3 guess he wants to play
Bishop g2 and discouraged Queen h4 I
could play Queen h4 and make of the boat
s gambits but I think that's a bit too
questionable do i plain out of six when
Knight f6 is so natural or Bishop c5
start with 906 no rush to take the pawn
oh maybe I should have taken the pond
well too late now
I've Bishop g4 if I want Bishop c5 looks
nice the thing about gambits you
willingly give away material to get
counter play to get other types of
advantages so here I have developments
lights a bit restricted because the
pawns on you for
yeah black Mardy Murie gambit is on the
list
Oh hammer used to play d4 d5 85 e 6
that's interesting
could consider that okay Bishop g2 so
there's pressure against upon in Queen
e7 is logical I just want to like push
my H pawn there's also just castling I
don't think I can take if I takes I play
rook e8 g3 i-5 in some line yeah it's
all about just developing and then later
going for the kill okay got some honey I
have to make this a sweet game what's
that your own gambits also the Albanian
oh maybe you mean the Albin counter
gambits I'll write that down counter
gambits
d3 okay d3 should generally make me
happy because I want to open the e-file
POS what does pls stand for mm-hmm
Bishop g4 92 I'm daydreaming of Bishop
g4 Queen d2 e3 chopping the Queen that
wouldn't happen though wait a minute
oh it's kind of close to working cuz I
can take on g1 first play Bishop g4 but
there's Knights EE - I don't know if I
want to give away my my dark squared
bishop there's also Knight g4 here then
Knight takes e4 attacking defending so
what to do 92 Bishop g4 92
I can take and play rook e8
I can hmm I can just take here and then
play rook e8 and Bishop c4 it looks
Pleasant
expecting Queen ticks I can also play
Knight g4 right away let's start with
this white can't legally castle at least
next move
so Bishop g4 a knight g4 it has a larger
threat to it
calculating 94-94 rook takes e4 I should
take c4 9f2 or queen takes e4 Knight f2
it seems like it's just trading stuff
fun of it thanks for subbing greetings
to you I mean I could play like Bishop
g4 Queen e7 or Queen e7 right away also
Knight a 6 to b4
problem with 96 was a three my nights
kind of stupid
yeah this is not easy looking at this
line again I'm realizing actually I have
after 94 I have Bishop f5 which actually
looks quite nice so Knight G 494 Bishop
f5 yeah I could live with that and
otherwise like White has to stop this or
this
it's White Knight g4 it's getting
interesting
yeah the faulk of your counter gambit
was now on my list the King's gambit was
on my list walk their counter so here's
my list for anyone just joining spend a
minute the beginning of the stream
writing down gambits
so we'll see how many I can play and how
many games I can win too
yeah the night and Bishop here
coordinating nicely I need four okay so
if I play this there's no night of six
that I take and defend
and now I'm threatening threatening to
play knife to or threatening to take and
then my left ooh so likes under some
pressure and it took me a while to like
find this move I had to consider 94 and
let's circle back to it wait I put honey
in my tea already I think I showed the
honey but I didn't put any how do you in
my teeth yes I don't think so
time to put honey in my tea okay wait
what the AI tries to describe the emote
that's nice thanks talk this for the a
half year sup wait 9 f - neither of two
forks everything it's a it's a quadruple
for the problem could be 9 f 6 check but
then I went at night I was a bishop I
trade Queens I win a rook so 9 F - yeah
the night's pinned so I mean like could
take but then get all win a queen
music man asking about a line and the
Queens gambit accepted yeah white should
play d5 in that variation to gain space
will usually win back the pawn later
okay let's take a knight and then do i
trade Queens first probably upper rook
and I don't think white can actually
trap the Knights my knight has a clear
escape route f2 will always be guarded
efore will be carded to
Bishop takes e4 was even simpler Oh
Bishop takes e4 what am I thinking I was
so excited to get the fork night
I forgot the fork Bishop can exist as
well just tunnel vision it goes back to
the simple idea when you see a good move
you should look for a better move hello
- Krishna should have listened to Tommy
everyone should listen to Tommy happy
birthday just for the charm 120-180
birthday congratulations
okay one game down 14 moves I'm hoping
to have a lot of quick games that's the
nature of playing gambits is you win
quickly you conserve energy you get more
games in Oh track sir gambits track sir
and it okay what things should I go for
let's play e4 and see what happens
oh there's also wing gamut you type in
wing wing gambit very Sicilian and also
wing gambit
versed French let's play the wing
gambits
be for Chomsky played this in a US
Championship
or was it coughs key or was it Karev now
I'm forgetting maybe it was gray of
again scoffs key oh there's also the
England gambit yeah right that time as
well I like the fact my opponents
thinking
I assume okay so I've I really haven't
studied this seriously but pretty sure
that after takes ideas a three and it's
kind of like a Banco where the white
opens up queenside files ooh
gambit declined well should I still try
and gambit or should I just take over
the center I'm just gonna take over the
center gambit paid off sometimes gambits
are declined and yeah poets don't want
free material I play Bishop III I should
a 3d6
I'll start with Bishop III
thinking I have ideas of knights coming
to see for WoW d5 so this bishops gonna
be annoying for black perhaps a queen g4
here then that loses a pawn hmm I have a
crazy idea
oh maybe it's too crazy
I was linking 92 here and I'd see four
but none just takes your play Bishop d3
slide Bishop d3 all that then takes
takes doesn't quite work either maybe
just a 5 let's play e5 yeah it's just
like a French or I'll have c3 and I'll
have a nice French structure not sure
why it took me so long to consider a5
and maybe I'll have a Greek gift like
Bishop d3 Knight f3
ooh so now okay it's a little bit
surprising because now the King's stuck
in the center
neither four could be a threat but
there's ways to deal with it maybe Queen
f3 first queen of three
also queen h5 or queen g4 let's play
Queen f3 stopping metaphor applying some
pressure I would like to play h4 very
soon there's some crazy line let's say
black plays Bishop g7 here h4 takes
Queen h5 that goes back to g6 might take
ticks ticks ticks ticks I don't know if
I'm winning material thunder were just
trading maybe were just trading or I
went up on oh but I'd lose up on to
probably just a trade school excuse me
I'm allergic to something allergic to
like seasons changing Bishop g7 okay oh
so this line could actually come to real
life
hmm let's play ch4 it's in the spirit of
Canada I'm cabbing in the H pawn whoa
Locke is ganda ting or just winning
material really that's kind of smart cuz
my my rook is gonna get trapped Wow
impressive
I'll admit I didn't see that
so I actually gamba to the pawn if I
take that everything crumbles like this
pawn will fall and I'm losing the rook
so maybe Queen g3 a queen g3 maybe keeps
me alive and what else to do
Oh Queen g3 still looking at lines where
I take like h5 doesn't seem so promising
okay I'm down upon where they go thanks
for rating with a party of three okay I
want to play h5 actually there's gonna
be some interesting compensation because
h5 the night moves I take on g7 and
there's still some looming threats of
taking the night maybe at the right time
but I don't think I'll win this game and
in 14 moves as like Lasky
maybe Locke will play h5 preventing me
from playing h5 combinatorial thanks for
subbing for five months yeah I'm playing
in the tournament two people want to
join the tournament I can share the link
in the checks
not sure what play Simon oh I'm in 174th
place okay got my work cut out all right
so this actually looks nice because I
can take I can play h5 how there's
Intermezzo f4 so maybe I take and play
out for myself
hmm don't really want to give away my
lights red bishop but let's do it
it's also throwing 9 f3 because I should
really develop my pieces h5 f4 is very
annoying
I could also play F for myself it makes
a lot of sense there weakens a king but
who cares about King safety
hater so great you've been streaming so
often in rows and Illuminati in Brazil
naughty thanks Carlos appreciate that
all right I'm gonna play night of three
I think f4o is to weakening as pawns
can't move backwards if black plays off
for I'll have an interesting decision
whether to play Queen h2 or Queen g5 I'm
down the pawn but I'm feeling some
compensation some some pressure just
love her like 292 now 92 as a move
probably should have considered it but
okay now 311 forces upon so if I play
Queen h2 threatening h5 black phase h5
and my Queens just stuck if I play Queen
g5 we trade Queens
I have an h-file
like when g5
trying to understand this position I'm
down upon but my bishops happy H files
and Isis plans a bit overextended I have
to develop ooh that could be a good move
it could be a very good move
I can play Bishop d6 give away my
amazing Bishop I'm like King d1
now this position is not good I have to
come back try and come back
maybe I should just develop 92 I'll go
down another pond but my my hopes are
that these ponds are gonna be weak in
some scenario I'll Castle queenside do I
sack another pond
thinking about queenside castling here
it looks very questionable but let's do
it I'm allowing black to take another
pawn that's the spirit of the stream
though I'm getting the whole game is a
gambit
it's true just gambling all the pawns
the more pawns I lose the more open
files I gain I have the half-opened
e-file I'll have the e-file soon
enjoying my h-file action right now I
have my bishop it's all about peace play
okay it's probably I could move my block
what to do I could take the night plane
out of three this [ __ ] takes here
threating this there's Bishop c6
I'm not liking what's fit what's
happening in the end there might not be
three also doesn't look so great also
I'm running low on time
there's rook h4 now
maybe 93
just preventing night III I'm allowing
night takes f3 but then at least the
pawns can I get fixed
I'll have the d4 square for my Knights
but ok if I'm gonna win this game it's
gonna require a small miracle or a large
miracle on time as bad positions bad but
raiding raiding differential is good for
me
I'm not sure how much I can use that so
defeat my opponent though
but okay these are these two pawns are
long-term weaknesses the thing is all my
pawns are long-term weaknesses as well I
think all of them I say that some of
them doubled play this move I actually
wouldn't mind like Bishop takes d4 be
happy to get some officer Clara Bishop
situation
to keep in mind to this rook is tied
down to the pond another sub I haven't
played one sadly sadly should join the
tournaments maybe we can play I do other
streams where I I take challenges from
from viewers and from subs so now if
you're a sub you can follow the
instructions from moobot or from night
bots and the chats you can add your your
leech s username and that will connect
it with your twitch name and then will
be more likely to play let's play rookie
you want do you want your rook t2 maybe
rook t2
after rook d2 I have access to the B
file also have the ability to double up
sooner
also I defend this pawn so maybe I can
play that f5 and do stuff and f5 would
be a nice square
okay time is running low for both of us
which probably gives me more chances
ooh interesting
maybe King be too flexible move
as many cases of c-3po needs defending
and now I can check and win this guy but
there's Bishop a5 in the end and rook c1
ok so I went out for so Bishop a5 I also
have rope t3
yeah this isn't so bad I feel like I'm
coming back like my pawns are actually
not so weak like everything everything's
defended except my rook but that doesn't
matter okay he wants to play rook c8
I'll serve with this this is a square
should be well supported it rook c8 can
I take what's my work t3 the rook looks
awkward but does its job another son
rough bananas thanks for subbing I had a
banana smoothie yesterday it was really
good it was just bananas and ice and
honey Bishop a5
forgot he could attack another time oh
you're playing Knights 92 then Bishop b5
maybe 92 hitting the pawn and defending
this pawn attacking and defending
so now black has two pawns hanging
so more reason to think if I can put the
bishop on g4 that would actually be like
very safe and solid and black would like
to play this but I think because I can
take it just doesn't work here's no time
to take this pawn b6
okay let's solidify I'm not interested
in winning either of these pawns at
least yet I'm just defending and now
I'll take a pawn and okay this was a
point of opening H file from earlier the
rook is now finding life and materials
is back to equal that's my a3 trying to
discourage b4 let's take something I'm
up upon I went from being down to pawns
being up upon and up on time life is
improving let's play Knight that's for
trying to win another pawn
not easy to defend if he plays Bishop c6
I win this pawn and then this will be
passed okay before I just take my knight
controls before Bishop c6 can I take
more okay seven it doesn't quite work
I play Knight b6 oh I could play this
move the rook is almost trapped rook has
to move here Oh free bishop okay the
gambit paid off I'm not sure if it was a
gambit paying off in just time situation
okay where's the mates check let's push
up pawn or no let's do this
okay like a g6 and this is this is a
triple cork and Amit's that's a nice
finish very nice finish okay two for two
that game was was questionable I think
someone saw someone mentioned earlier
that maybe I missed something related to
this position of taking and then taking
in the night c3 and I'll admit I didn't
consider this but it doesn't look good
like there's Queenie five ideas or Roxy
aids and yeah black still winning
material so I think I made the right
decision Queen g3 yeah I mean it's still
looking pretty patch for what else but
manage somehow untangle
yeah queen c8 is a interesting move from
computer hard to play as black though
because h5 looks scary ok interesting
game back to tournaments two out of two
can you do one in the London there's not
too many gambits in the London last
opponent plays a Dutch well there's so
many gamuts against the Dutch ovn again
that's I don't think I wrote that down
PN again it's Marshall gambit also for
the deeper there's a couple Marshall
gambits
okay I'm black b3 what can Becan playing
in is b3 can i gambit anything here oh
yeah a5 gambling the a pawn in some
positions actually a5 has been what is
this I wanted to play a four do I played
B 5 B 5 and then C 6 to accelerate
development let's do it b5 I don't think
this has a name but I'm gonna apply the
principle of gamma D and giveaway upon
to accelerate development don't try this
at home kids where we're violating many
opening principles not developing not
controlling the center giving away
material but ok now I'm developing and
controlling the center
and now I think the what is the theory
here one night have six let's start with
the nights
and one idea is to play a four soon
I'll play Queen b6 and I want to apply
pressure with my queen and rook and pawn
okay let's start with this move the
bishop belongs on a nice long diagonal
maybe I'll play g5 the combination of g5
and Bishop b7 actually works well
together
again I just want to open up lines after
Knight takes d5 rook e8 and I don't even
know if I'm like losing uh losing the
pawn because I should win it back after
h6
oh there's some other interesting moves
like Knight d4 to consider my options
hmm let's start with this
expecting line of three whoa 97 what
does 97 that's interesting
all right I'll take and then take on G
to still down upon but it's an
interesting position if Queen f3 I have
a really nice move please play Queen f3
and 9 f3
I was thinking Aquino 394 and then I I
just do everything I still play 94 year
94 is interesting
oh it's so hard to resist let's play 94
I'm gambling a night
this is such a weird position so I
haven't moved like my to seven columns
kind of developing on the wings the idea
of 94 is after it takes I have Queen
check and then if the King Mustafa have
Queen h3 if something blocks on e4 I
just take it or play d5 after take
stakes of 92 I have Bishop after three
with a the monster came Bishop f5 Bishop
d3 what is H for random move very random
move I think it's time to go for the
kill
I'm not a three check that was the point
of knights 94 I'm trying to understand
the logic of each sport maybe it's a
create room for the rook but now I can
take yeah this is gonna end pretty
brutally for whites I defend my rook the
King has to move back or the Queen has
to take now I can take on e3 everything
falling we need to okay I could take it
sorry quicker mates let's just take it
my rook is hanging
rough game
now's not the time for a boat s gambit
Oh my opponent left in a few seconds
that should give me the option to claim
victory I would hope I was thinking
after Knight takes rook if I play this I
play this or if I just take the rook
it's calculating this this
it's probably best just to take the rook
and then go back to to f3
all right let's come up with more
gambits here's my list
I hope the text isn't too small
oh no people should see it oh wait I
don't want to cover the potential claim
victory bun we move it to the other side
or I'll just cover the board with it
we don't need this quadrant of the board
okay so we had the Marshall gammas
oh the elephant gamut that's be 45 not
3d 5 right
I live in canvas consider that yeah
botas gambit where's the boat s gambit
boat s kinda I have so this is no tat I
can't can i bold something control
people no I can't
what's the Colorado gambit
oh the Colorado gambit is that like I
think Colorado claim victory yeah we
chess was great where it detects you
situations yeah back to turn news
Colorado gambit is efore and knight c6
Knight a3 f5 right there's something
like that oh there's a Tennyson ganda to
it spelled like this maybe that would
require white playing a scan you never
heard of the where gambit make my own
gambit that's what I did last game my
last game was slightly strange it was
this physician this is my own gambit all
right playing oh so two roads DF Oh
where's my list I guess I'll play e4
again
because before has the most options
oh the filled or counter gambit I gave
some idea okay um I play the winged
gambit uh the second game of the stream
so I'll play uh Smith Cora gambits great
some mayhem make us from and happy
wherever he is please accept you know
you want you okay Smith more that time
I'm not like super booked up but I know
I know a thing or two Queen c7 so early
Quincy South and I haven't seen this
move order before Queen c7 prevents
Bishop c4 because usually I play knight
c6 Bishop c4 then Queen c7 there has to
be a reason why Queen c7 is not play I'm
not sure why play e5
I mean I could play Knight b5 maybe
Knight b5 the Queen moves here or here I
just attack with the bishop if the Queen
moves elsewhere
I play Bishop f4 hitting c7 oh but
there's Bishop before check but just
before Bishop d2 then I have C file
ideas let's do it
not sure if this is a right approach but
it looks fun
okay Bishop t2 I'll take with the Queen
if he takes yeah this is troublesome for
black because 96 is coming I have double
threats do I start with 96 do I start
with rooks even one
there's also actually there's a nice
move here queen c3 which is essentially
a fork attacking this and this it's
writing 96 the thing about queen c3 is
that there's King f8 open I have 97 so I
have a triple threat queen c3 is
threatening this this and this
all of which wind material let's play
queen c3 oh there's also Queen here
wait Queen here can just be devastating
but 997 or even 96 96
okay I'm playing Queen C 3 because I
didn't see what to do after 96 I'm sure
it's like somehow good for a whites but
this I think pretty clearly wins
material ooh knight c6 I can take if
Queen f6 I just take in night c7 and
there's Queen a5 Queen 85 just Knight c3
or 92 yeah I would imagine this is a
reason why I start with check how do I
take it probably doesn't matter I also
have this check a few things to think
about linking e7
um yeah let's start with this check I'm
guessing this is probably by Queen c7
isn't it should not be play line move 5
now take and take here so black actually
might be getting some compensation
because my knight might get trapped I'm
temporarily up a full rook to develop a
tempo but Knight c5 though unite c5 rip
d1 even castling queenside could make
some sense I'm not sure where my king
wants to go oh I think I'll play rook do
you want
there's pros and cons it probably
doesn't make a huge difference in the
grand scheme of things I was thinking if
I Castle or if I play Rick do you want
to keep the C 1 square open but if I
Castle queenside I get rookie one sooner
hmm the King could be a target on c1
yeah let's play Rick do you want I
assume blacks gonna go for like this
idea to win the night and I'm not sure
if I have any like rescue mission
probably not even Elon Musk can rescue
this Knight but I have ideas of camera
play like Knight g5 maybe I can create
some distraction Knight g5 like if we
imagine B 6 Knight g5 and if the King
moves somewhere I have night c7 let's do
it cuz the rook is actually kind of
stuck if it moves to f8 I take keep the
initiative so
yeah sometimes it's a nice strategy to
create chaos um like a different area of
the board like if you can't defend
counter-attack tipsy ton is sick of
these moral pleasures yeah you can blame
a sermon for that
I'm not sure what black does here
there's 95 but 95 rook probably rookie 3
and then like the Knights not defended
and aside down to this bad things would
happen to black yo me has never played
the mora I feel like every chess player
should probably play play them more or
play like a an aggressive gambit at some
points just to appreciate of giving away
material for for active play but there's
also a lot of logic just just being
solid and slowly grind down the phonons
without taking risks he likes a Colorado
wait what's the bucer is a pucker or
buker
yeah maybe next game I'll try and play
some Colorado or play what I think is a
Colorado
imagining this line rock cafe ticks or
goes back and then like math six ideas
to target D seven
okay there will be options how do I like
the caveman against a caro-kann I don't
know what that is there's a lot of like
gambits people are mentioning that I
just have not heard of I've heard of the
apocalypse variation against a carro con
but caveman what would the caveman be
caveman I assume is pushing like wing
pawns maybe some variation in the dance
with like H for a G for watch out for
the T oh yeah I have a spoon in my tea
let's pour some more tea and take away
the spoon
oh it's Bishop c4
yeah Carlson has played that I remember
looking into that think objectively it's
not that great but it's an interesting
surprised variation I'll add that to the
list variation all right let's take a
spawn so now I have a passed pawn
another Saab abstract envy thanks for
subbing for two months so do I play this
I play this and I guess I tie down the
bishop and then there's rook h6
I have to move the night then maybe just
95 still attacking f7 and now what to do
play this move its bits subway 110 in hi
how long is your student waiting list
how long is my student waiting list
oh it's I have to check I'm gonna play
Rock f3 first of all thanks for the bits
there's there has to be at least like 30
names on it before I've been busy has
it's been hard to to take new students
recently
okay so f5 let's move back now I have a
threat so I'm keeping initiative I'm
hitting I hit the f7 pawn now I'm
hitting a six pawn threatening
threatening the fork and wanting to
rescue my knight Knight rook f6 good
move
I mean maybe I just push up on like H
forward bishop here h5 bishop takes h6
I'm up the exchange in that line rook h8
h 7 rook rook f8 h 7 h8 and then I fork
in the end it's actually nice I don't
care about the knight anymore I'll have
a new piece enter the corner a new more
powerful piece so H 7 is pretty much
unstoppable
yeah actually Black has no time okay
there's a smooth oh there's that move by
could still page 7
maybe Brooke
each seven-night Ickx King D to rook F a
die queen I win this thing in the end
yeah let's do it
I could even like after work I feel I
could take the night to or okay now just
queen
and he forced mate this is good enough
my night controls the forking square
could win the night or I can maybe go
for mates let's try and go for Nate's
yeah I think this is maybe force making
be 798 King a six Queen a fours mate and
if yes the King has a few options here
King a eights just work h8 should do the
job
oh there's a caution gambits Carlsen
plating is ding it's against the Petrov
let's fight 98 okay I was nice what camp
it was oh that was Smith Memorial oh
yeah that was a nice line wonder was
that the was that the best approach I
mean 95 I think it's so like so thematic
yeah III should be up there okay that
was a fuel good game let's move on 40th
place 12 points I don't know if I'll
play the whole arena I'll try and fit in
a few more games playing Bulgari 1979 d4
okay well oh there's a um oh what's the
name of the gambits not the binco the
Blumenthal gambit Blumenfeld is another
one but I'm gonna play the Budapest
because I love the Budapest I can't
resist
I could play me be a tricky variation
but I'll play Maya I'll play in my
repertoire I did a small video series on
the Budapest at the beginning of the
year may like three videos there on
YouTube of opening traps in the Budapest
III gives back the pond
it's a playable line
ah I was too late to play the the
fireworks can keep that in mind for a
future game and why I'm so inclined to
play a five so soon play knight c6 first
I should play 96 first it's the most
flexible move
and later I'll decide between like
Bishop before Bishop c5 play Bishop b4
here expecting Bishop d2 this is a
slightly different move order and then I
I would normally face but we still have
the kind of general structure of the
Budapest and the the main plan for block
is the castle usually puts my castle
first here play a thigh first maybe I'll
play 8 v first
just to slow down lights expansion so
their work usually comes to Yates
it could be interesting if white
castle's queenside looks like whites
going to Castle kingside so even though
this was a gambit I'm not it's down upon
opponent gave act upon willingly and now
we have a position I will still try and
play aggressively and if I castles King
side there's a very thematic idea I'm
excited to play ok whichever way white
castles I'm gonna have some attack
hopefully yeah the rook lift is coming
this is very typical in the Budapest it
doesn't happen in like so many other
openings that in this case the whole six
Frank four pack it's entirely clear no
pawns in the way it's one of the reasons
for delaying d6 put the bishop on f8 it
was one of the reasons for rookie aides
the bishops here it can get attacked
forever with 94 maybe some day the
bishop will come back to life okay do I
care about my a pawn
probably not allowing white to take in
White has done attacking the C pawn but
I can lock white take both pawns and I
can just go for me
efore for some reason I forgot about he
for
probably have to move the rook again
let's play let's play for g6 just
aligning with the king I want to play
Queen h4 I want to play d6 in Bishop h3
and enjoy the attack how do you decide
whether to put the rook on h6 for g6
usually it comes down to what your main
target is whether it's h2 or g2 also
comes down to whether lights controlling
one of these squares like I guess I
could have played with g6 immediately
I do have Queen g5 but the thing about
rook g6 is Knight f4 happens to be
interesting if my players like a thwart
here just trying to refute my whole
variation opponent is thinking I'm sure
there's many choices for whites
before
before was not expected it doesn't seem
so relevant in the grand scheme of
things but I mean that it gives me the
move well there's a funny line Queen h4
and I take c7 Bishop d6 Knight takes
Knight f3 I stock a pawn a rook a knight
and then I made on each seven let's play
Queen h4 oh oops I hung upon just in
case my phone is watching you can take a
free pawn probably not a great idea to
say that line beforehand and then try
and trick them well again I don't know
if my phones watching might just be
acting for no one
okay so I think in this case both G 2
and H 2 are targets like there's ideas
of course Bishop d6 ideas Queen H 3 d6
Bishop H 3 still Knight g4 maybe f3 and
Feingold would be disappointed what to
play
I mean this can't be a good move there's
no way but how do i punish it I got
played by 56 with immediate threats
let's do it so I have my bishop my rook
my knight my queen what does white have
defending three pawns maybe a rook kind
of a bishop but the point is I think I
have more attackers and white has
defenders I'm threatening some some
nasty threats it's not so easy for a way
to stop imagining like oh maybe play the
move like Bishop II one train
counter-attack
now g3 could be interesting as well if
g3 or uptakes g3 wait does that work
ticks ticks king each one probably
Knight takes f3 then queen h2 is
basically unstoppable I think or Queenie
Sri unstoppable yeah this is why I like
the Budapest especially fare like
Blitzer rapid because like the idea is
kind of go deep into the middle game
especially with this rook maneuver and
while the players will kind of play
naturally and then stumble into an
attack like this so am I just meeting
here i takes f3
if rook takes off three its meaning to
and then takes out three only shows the
bishop so Knight takes f3 if Bishop
takes off three I I take with the bishop
King here i play this move blocking the
attacking goes back and then I'm eight
I'm asking each one I just made
immediately yeah this is nice
Bishop g3 multi-purpose controlling f2
and not allowing Bishop takes h4
nice finish another miniature if you
threaten the threat does a threat become
not a threat it's too complicated of a
question
there's other threat to me I'm
threatening me with a a that's right in
question okay GG that was fun cuz like
even like reaching the middle game it
just doesn't seem like Bach has an
attack but very quickly
just came to life I think the move I was
most scared of here was my escort and
then I wasn't sure what I was gonna do
aw nice March
thanks for the bits maybe I would like
repeat once I have for a row gauge 695
and then like maybe flavor of g6 or rook
c6 I have some some choices okay back to
tournament 26 place who's in first
Andre bori is running away with it but
probably not having as much fun as I am
this is the longest meet you ever
calculated over the board I do not know
all right don't remember
I mean I've I've had some like very long
calculations over the board like
extending like beyond 15 moves ask me
that again at a later point when I'm not
playing a tournament and then I'll I'll
try and like actually research the
answer how often you play over the board
tournaments a few times a year these
days okay what to play let's play
another efore I think I'll stick with e4
mostly this tournaments okay I can play
could play a Danish place scotch
it's pretty nice three let's see what
black is up to
Phil I'm playing a strong player
okay I'll play a Halloween gambit
because Halloween is coming up
Halloween time maybe not the best life
decision but it is a decision after 96 I
think this move right
or is it dry play d5 maybe up to 85
that's got to be this move forcing like
that to GE its
okay I gather the whole piece while box
giving a pack she's scared okay well
we're gonna have like a reasonably solid
position for both of us honestly
sometimes this is the way I like to play
against a Halloween it's a simple low
risk but the knight ISM I think a bit
misplaced on c6 should also know that
I'm setting up a trap if block kicks
upon then I I have Bishop h7 in the end
apologies for four arrows all right the
endgame is approaching actually thinking
about just trading Queens like Queen f3
takes takes takes takes it's gonna be
very positional I know this is not what
you guys signed up for but it's part of
life expecting takes maybe there's 97 97
Wow I could play g4 force matters g4 is
interesting
maybe I will
good throwing rookie one
let's play g4
just making sure there's no like sneaky
tricks I was looking for a moment of
queen g6 but it doesn't work cuz I just
take twice okay
we have a slightly imbalance on game I
have double ponds black has oval Hans
and black swans should get a little bit
weaker than mine
it's Bishop versus Knights Nicola start
soon sandwich time smiley face
thanks Nicola and have sandwiches for
like the whole week now I played Bishop
g5 and just went up on oh no f6 hmm I
kept like g5 I think the problem with g5
the thing like pawn structure starts
getting fixed I don't want to pawn fixed
on the dark square cousin I hear f4 can
come so I'm inclined just to play h3 I
think about h3 is takes an f5 again and
F file opens so I can consider f3
there's also this move Bishop f4
not entirely sure what to do here the
king h1 Ritchie one
I could just take
I don't know why f3 looks so most
attractive it looks so looks weird but
maybe it's logical
just leaving tension I'll play off three
cuz if black takes like I guess I'm
happy to open that file yeah
when in doubt play f3 always play off
three right and I think it's to my
benefit to have pawns on light squares
if pawns control light squares Bishop
controls dark squares eventually I'll
control all the squares on the board or
at least maximize the number of squares
I control a fine cold fine gold just
rolled his rolled over in his grave
pretty sure he's still alive that joke
might be valid in like a hundred years
okay take sticks on Bishop c5 comes rook
e1 comes I have temple moves like this
this and this come with tempo all of
these things can be targeted I'm just
trying to design a nice thumbnail for
YouTube I don't think I saw I I would
never make GM I just said it's not like
a top priority for me I would be okay if
I I never end up making it but yeah
there's other other priorities in life I
think my opponent is terrified with my
arrows it would be interesting if like
when you draw arrows opponent could also
see them you can mess with them guess my
opponent might be seeing them if he's
watching the stream
yeah to become a GM it would require
full devotion to studying and playing
would have to teach a lot less and
stream a lot less and play a lot more
like international tournaments it's not
an easy lifestyle it would be an
interesting lifestyle though I have six
and Feingold's probably jumping with joy
if it was opposite day okay so I just
play this move hit the pond
lock defends probably or c6 I think the
problem is I play out this should f-4c
Sixers eventually night g6 black play
Bishop d6 rook ta tix
just calculating some and I have some
random line so I should start with
Bishop f4
I guess the calculation depends on what
I play after ac6 because I can consider
like this move and maybe went up on
actually wait c6 Bishop d6 pinning and
attacking rook e8 rook a AE one night g6
my take mr. slates oh there's no nice
yet this is interesting
maybe c6 isn't the best move for a black
okay I think I should just go for this
there's rook f7
I'm not seeing what blocks gonna do
against this maybe King f7 guess I'll
find out
oh there's not h4
when I teach for yeah there's some takes
knowledge for
I can't defend their five
good play King have to hear some
reasonable move each for each work can
be interesting to idea after it takes to
play Bishop here but that doesn't work I
don't think takes here
it was rookie six for thinking of seven
I play Bishop pure F for Bishop F to my
bishop would be sad I'm just going to
keep the tension time is becoming more
relevant
I was hoping to in the pond but not the
case
for the time being the night's
restricted as a bishop controls all the
squares a knight moves towards the
center now this looks interesting
each for it takes in an idea of this but
then ro takes II one so I could take
first and then play h4
still consider this
throwing rookie one first
I've some crazy line which I don't see
anything wrong with in the play it's I
would have said it but it takes too long
to say and time has become an issue
so yeah the ideas after it takes now I
play this there's no takes anyone if
work t8 I play Bishop g3f for Bishop
here starting h5 I guess one issue could
be the e-file I mean at the very least I
can take
hmm
Oh to do maybe this yeah we might go
into some like Bishop versus night and
game I'm expecting this and I'm not sure
whether to play rook b2 or rook e1 don't
see anything wrong with rook b2
I still want to take your the main
threat if takes here okay so that that's
some move now rugby to
so I was envisioning something like this
earlier I'm thinking that I have h5
follow that Bishop takes f4 but it's
still still tricky to understand
and not entirely sure what's going on
there's there's a line to calculate
yes I can draw arrows here here here
here here here
I think I'm defending everything I mean
there's rook takes F 3 then rook F 2 or
takes c3 Bishop g5 I have to go for this
so it's all being played out I hope as
f6 is targeted in the end
kingi one defense discovery defends ooh
didn't see that coming can I just trap
the night what is this the Knights
trapped I think
is this too good to be true let's trap
tonight and defend the pawn at the same
time opponent resigns that was really
abrupt it's not expecting the game time
like that at all
what a game analysis boring what was a
oh I played the Halloween II ended hey I
beat a decently high rated player with
the Halloween gambit but it was sort of
a Halloween gannets returned her
declines I just gave up the case yeah
it's very positional yeah when I play
Brooke b1 I was envisioning the the
situation where like I played Bishop g3f
for Bishop h2 it was hard to judge
whether he file would be a problem okay
I see the computer evaluation but I
really wasn't sure like after this line
like because I was calculating this
thinking bishop or uh rook F - I think
practically it looks very scary for
black so I'm threatening this maybe the
computer find some refutation but she
Bishop c5 can maybe trap the Knights
okay what does engine say what says - to
look after - ah rookie for rookie
forests pretty tragic for white the
chief war is I'm falling
yeah well okay it was a nice interesting
game a sad finished for my opponents
things flow though oh nine for the sub
for two months let's go back to the
tournament so I've played what are the
gambit side played so far I play the
Budapest I'm not like cut and paste so I
play Budapest I play the faulkner
counter gambit
I still have a lot of gambits I haven't
played let's play let's play kiyomi's
opening I assume this is a Colorado I
might be mistaken so what's the point of
the Colorado d5 probably I assume d5 or
is it nine of six I'm not gonna look at
the chat I should figure this out on my
own and it's gotta be t5 because there's
no Queen h5 ideas yet I'm weakening the
square though okay I just want to win
back the pawn open that file
maybe Castle queenside even this could
be fun I had the Colorado to my um my
list of plague andit's
if one is thinking that's the nice thing
about playing like you're really off
beat Bazar opening is that players start
thinking earlier at least some players
that's nice have a time advantage and
have initiative I did play the Halloween
that was the last game I'll add that to
the list as well I played oh I played
swift Maura and I played the wing gambit
against Sicilian so for those of you
curious while we wait for the pawns move
this is my kind of master list of
gambits and these are the gambits I
played so far this stream I think this
is the guy played the six games so far
this is my sixth game Oh
john davis asking if you get a second
can you show us a master list of Cabot's
yeah i can move it right here g4 oh this
is reminiscent of Kings gambit I mean
this is like this is gonna be a reverse
Kings gambit I think there's a line in
Kings gambit where the pawns here which
probably makes a big difference I mean I
assume that I should go for this I mean
h5 looks very logical it's weakening but
I just want to tear down the pawn chain
because there's no h3 was I take and
there's a pin if this pawn goes away
then I win this phone with the bishop so
d4 not sure if I fully understand whites
play so now I can take hitting the night
and threatening to win the pawn maybe I
take this first yeah just so I'm not
losing G for my up upon I'm up upon I've
only lost one pawn there's a first pawn
from for f5 I can play g6 here there's a
reinforce it's kind of a mini chain let
the bishop I want that u6 and be solid
Casey Kenny wow thanks for subbing new
sub that's your one is Ashley min really
categorize desig andit's I think so
I mean f5 against the Spanish looks very
candid like I'm sure there's some lines
where like yeah there's definitely lines
where white keeps the pond in black its
comp all right I'm gonna play you 6
yeah this bishop is very solid and even
though like the pawns are pollen lights
for is it's a good Bishop it's all
supporting its kind of outside this pawn
chain I'll put this Bishop on c5 I don't
think white has any compensation here I
will come to e7 it's still gonna be a
fight
play d4
I think I should just play positionally
or c6 - maybe c6 preparing some like
Queen some type of Queen move hmm I was
kind of expecting that maybe b5 let's do
it
so many things on light squares maybe a
5 a 4 is common okay come play Queen a 5
here threatening be for my king is safe
it's just safe in the center Center is
pretty closed this is interesting move
because the knight might be preparing
some something sort of move I could play
Bishop before still may be considered e4
should calculate b4 because light has
one square I can win another pawn
I mean Bishop before it just looks very
pleasant though yeah as d4 is the
threats supersymmetry that's great
thus loving but not not asking me a
question asking good prophet the
question favorite get commands I don't
even know if I can Nina get command
there's math dot random I get command
maybe yeah it's not easy to stop d4 okay
Saul undable to G pawns not so depressed
about losing the the bishop my my pawn
still do a good job of controlling light
squares I guess I'm not threatening d4
anymore
while Bishop f6 Bishop f6 I should
probably take that but I also have rook
h3 but then there's Queen g5 it could
get messy maybe take sticks work h3 is
still Queen g5 I don't want like an
accident tab
I could just take in Castle queenside
leave the pawn enough six
I feel like I should just take it and
maybe even take on c3 working f7 first
new king f7 looks solid
just have to make sure the queen is not
entering
I think it's okay there's two blinds I
was calculating Thomas
thanks for the bits challenges Eric I'm
not I'm playing in the rapid arena you
can join the tournament here Queen D for
Queen g4 it's probably a decent move
defending the pond getting out of the
pin let's just take this is so unusual
pawn structure like for both of us
like White has all isolated pawns two
double pawns F pawns are kind of
detached from it to check each other I
have most of my pawns on light squares
but I am up a pond I have some attacking
move thinking just Queen c7 Queen C
Saturn very multi-purpose preparing this
or this or Jesus I think the plan is to
remove the Queen from the center and
then win the pawn and then maybe win
connect five or connect six
okay but you six is kind of a target
so the c5 makes sense see 523
[Music]
maybe just rook
let's start with rook e8 there's rookie
five
and this should be fine
I just want to play e5 still want to win
that six steak six dick mmm making me
hungry so I can play c5 Queen e3 oh
there's some sad line Queen III rock h3
Queen g5 Queen takes d5 I got me that
ooh but maybe I throw in so c5 23 rock
h3 Queen g5 rook g8 and then the Queen
has no great squares has to move to f4
then I play this move then the queen is
actually detached from the rook oh but
then there's rook takes no not rook
takes off for it looks good on Stuart's
that looks pretty forcing - maybe Queen
f4 it was a move to play so I could okay
I can of course take on a six but this
looks fun
oh there's one more line to look at
let's just go for this
me too I forgot about that move but I
don't think it's too scary so I could
take on f6 maybe just rook h6 and win
the pawn like that
or maybe just take on C 327 first
in Queen d7 looks solid
the idea is after rook here there's no
threat of this or this because my Brooks
defended it a second time also I'm very
long time I have to start moving quicker
I think I can just take the pond
I'm up I'm up all other plans I have
still seven ponds Queen d2 what's idea
maybe before I shouldn't get some
counterplay before it takes like rook
maybe queen bee five now maybe it just
takes back
see for a while c4 is a good move
should probably what do I play here
c4 is very good move okay let's play
this move losing losing some stuff back
I get an e5 it'll lose before as well
the pawns are falling it's a delayed
gambit
well this work is very nice so let's
play this move 57 seconds I was just
negligent on time and preventing Queen I
fades
materials equal I have prettier pawns
play rook c8 target c4
now hitting the pond
if this maybe this a six looks good
rook b6 I take
user k5 within the rooks trapped
okay I want to play this move
hmm
how to break through maybe this move I
don't play this and then this
what Oh interesting
very interesting
ooh
either a could take actually okay I
think it was better to take with the B
rook so now I'm actually down upon its
actual gambit but if my pawns are
smiling so it can't be that bad
let's push some
okay it should not be difficult to win
some of white spawns but it will be
difficult to win the game with 23
seconds left
Connect for high win if only those were
the rules three okay this is gotta be
mine it's gotta be pawns are being
pushed e 2 1 square away f3 coming
ooh can build a bridge I'll promote with
check
not that it matters so much oh maybe it
doesn't matter cuz if you're the I
promote with check there's no Ricky
eight
what a game I missed amazing one I miss
them either one here oh I worked out
what again yeah that took work I was
feeling very comfortable got too
comfortable and then I mean I won
Connect four I had so in chess
I won't connect four with my final four
pawns that's nice yeah I don't know if I
was ever like in severe trouble but
around here like the pawns were falling
momentum was in White's favor was able
to recuperate I like this idea Queen
Queen here but I think in white should
take with the rook five thousand bits
from heart wise and Noble think so much
heart wise and it'll really appreciate
that
long time no see and sewer supersymmetry
do anything five dollars five hundred
years yes yes yes no no yes no yes yes
yes yes no no I think I was actually in
trouble if if rook takes because if I
take the rook then there's there's pawn
takes and my tun doubles the pawns but
maybe it's a race but then White's
running to push with check if I don't
take I could play III immediately it's
still race
well maybe this is okay steak steak
sticks I'm cleaning with check this is
winning
should be winning computers just
confused okay I think I have time for
one more game I'll try and get in one
more gambit in 14th place 13 just under
14 minutes left
are you the dude who used to sit in
front of that nice brick wall well i've
i've streamed from many many locations
so i probably at some point streams in
front of a brick wall oh we have a
french okay i'm gonna play i'm gonna try
and play the wing gambits I'll see what
black does yeah so the wing gamut
against a French involves e5 usually c5
and then b4 it's a line I haven't played
in a while used to play it a little bit
in blitz mister teach it to some
students to the idea is after it takes
which black is not doing I would play a
three so we have a wing gambit declined
I think this is nice though because d4
and c3 will come and I essentially
traded a a wing pawn for a more central
pawn
and yeah the problem for black this is
like an advanced variation except
there's not much pressure on the center
because there's no c5 in and I get C 3
and so d4 will be realm forests and
there might even be great gift ideas I
had the very similar position earlier
emerging from Sicilian Wing gambit where
I had blundered early and like allowed
some tactic on d4 but ok in this game
I'll be a bit more careful my bishop
will find a happy square on e3 Wow each
six let's play
because each six kind of prevents stuff
from coming to g5 you're playing that h4
maybe
what's idea than I teach fourth probably
just to restrict this night I'm being
hyper aware of this tactic happened in
the previous scheme like night each
fortnight takes d4 should be okay
because I have 92 I apply each five to
each five or h4 h5 well it's by h4 I
like this just got a pawn to h5 fix
black if Knight a5 I have g4 if Queen c7
maybe just Bishop d6 make the Queen
you're back this looks very pleasant
hmm I guess h5
no rush
my black is is very much I've short on
space kind of suffocating not a great
position for someone who's
claustrophobic a six maybe a six idea to
eventually play b5 I could play a four
just to show my dominance I could lift
my rook to perhaps I just put the rook
here how does Bach defend g7
there's not a five
[Music]
let's play Brooke h3
so I want to play this if I get into Rho
G 3 Rho G a there's a bishop h7 red
shade I take and defend the bishop
if not fires I can consider taking I
probably move back to a three
not really not sure with lactose a very
difficult position to be black
visioning somehow getting a Knight to d6
I would be happy but difficult to
accomplish
okay I'll play Bishop III no need to
actually Sh I should probably at least
consider this like takes takes rook g3
then black can play rotates
hmm yeah let's just play Bishop III
visioning some line where the Queen's on
d2 and then I take take here Rupp she
ate and then take on each six lift takes
them there's meat valuable Bishop Knight
a5 okay buck has some some potential
foreplay
I mean Knight c4 is coming I could play
g4 let's just play g4 kind of give up on
the roof g3 ideas but I kick the night
back just trying to still dominate the
position
I still have to deal with night-night c4
I mean I want to play 92 but Queen takes
c3 is actually kind of annoying
does it before here
ninety-two
I mean I'm imagining lines where I Isacc
the c-pawn and have some tactics but I
don't see anything that works
so bishop before
calculating bishop before and I see 492
a five my bishop is very short on
squares I could take King takes ooh
maybe I can take with Bishop play 94 it
opens up blacks bishop but I get 96 I'm
not sure if I want that
another option is just Queen c2 and I
see for Bishop c1 which is kind of sad
but also solid let's do it gonna be
solid I'm gonna try and just keep
control just build a little bit of tea
okay Bishop c1
yeah preserving the digit 9 c4 is a good
piece because it it controls d6 so I
couldn't plant the bishop on d6 I don't
want to take and make this bishop happy
let's play for a4 is useful to control
the be 5 square
and soon I want to play Knight 92 I
didn't like 16 night ft2 Oh a night off
tteyuu I didn't even consider 9 ft too
if I saw this move I probably wanna play
that because I keep c3 control I should
have played that f2 you two good points
but ok I'm still happy complain 92 here
Knight bTW 2
[Music]
IPD two takes takes rook c8 it's also 93
I have a weird idea that to play like
this night is not great on f3 I think
the night belongs on e - I think I might
just play Knight and g1 on developing to
get in 92 wow castling queenside I was
slightly unexpected okay I should start
with 92 and then decide where I'm
putting my Knights okay that makes me
happy I think I can play 93 here a4
should not fall if takes a four I mean
at the very least I just take here win
the bishop and then and if takes I just
want to get the bishop back to d6
hmmm interesting so I could I could take
on c4 but the bishop on e4 but then
there's a 95 not afore I could keep
tension to play rook b1
hmm
to play g5 here okay I'll give black the
d5 square a bishop on e4 just looks so
nice and there's no pressure on c3
anymore this is this is gonna be a fight
maybe Bishop d2 or Bishop a3 let's play
Bishop a3 okay if takes I just win
immediately Bishop d6 coming time is low
but position is still nice maybe some
eyes you to play rook f3 because there's
no rug off a rook eye fades
I should've controls that fades if f6 I
just take twice even
trying to calculate like f6 takes take
sticks then there's attempt to take here
but doesn't work as the Knights pinned
you know so Bishop Yates may be the only
way to defend 9f for as possible work be
one also possible 56 let's play Bishop
d6 oh no I don't want to a lot off six
or f5 for maybe just King up on just
being safe
see what black is up to I think the king
is best on g1 just so there's no
potential night tactics it's a position
where I have everything controlled I
think things are defended it's not clear
what Locke is doing so I think I'm
betting like best off just making slow
improving moves it's also easier for the
time situation to play just simple
improving moves rather than to force
matters
yeah I really don't know what blacks
doing here g6 there we go okay I could
take but then the rook is a bit targeted
Knight g3 just supporting stuff
another sub chanchad thanks for subbing
f5 what does that fact you forget about
mom to son maybe he might opponent just
forgot those f7 is coming this camping
your Trebek slightly surprising I was
expecting like takes four g8 I could
play off seven immediately I mean let's
just take
yeah this looks very nice plenty of time
he didn't forget he's just getting
desperate
and that's possible but I don't think
there is like any immediate threat for
me maybe just trying to confuse or
complicate things with the time
situation
okay the rook is happy here I want to
play Bishop g6 but then it leaves my
rook undefended there might be tactics
the bishops best here anyway
what should you you know what do I do
here between c1 or Queen d2
the Queen d2 target h6
another sub fact for us
thanks for something okay I have to say
focus it's the final game I want to keep
keep my result clean this tournament
even though this game won't count for
the tournament g5 that's a good move
do I do here I just don't see what to do
your rook let's defend a place safe
might even like bring the bishop back to
see one play Queen c2 we see two first
okay at least I have an idea and pretty
much everything's defended might still
pinned h6 will be the maybe in the next
victim now the Knights unpinned but the
Queen is less scary in Bishop g6 could
be possible at some point but I might
just want to take for the bishop here
push the pawn if I get the Bishop to g7
that I control h6h 7nh aids with my
bishops the final arrow time situation
is becoming better Queen d6
yeah and Bishop g7 cuts off the rook so
there's no more no more battery
hmm I think this is desperation I still
have to be careful oh this should be
completely fine
I have Bishop e5 I can just take a few
times up a full rook Queen g2
oh no I got needed no I got made it what
a sad finish I didn't see the battery
with the bishop Oh such a nice game - I
gotta meet her like that
I just got careless I didn't see box
threats should have been such a nice
game - was up before rugby until I got
needed I was just like I was getting too
comfortable I was expecting this and
this resigns
that's funny here like I was deciding
between this and this
d5 loses a bishop but also still gets me
that and this Bishop was just irrelevant
to me so say well I'm probably gonna put
this whole stream on YouTube apologies
for the sad finish don't leave too many
mean comments and I hope you guys enjoy
that it was different sort of stream had
a nice list of gamuts I played I played
wing Gavin against French against
Sicilian I played Budapest Faulkner
counter again to Colorado game at
Halloween gamuts and I was 5 out of was
my score
though that game doesn't count for the
tournament slice undefeated in the
tournament I'll leave it at that
the England gambits I didn't get a
chance to play the England gambits
congratulations Andre bori for winning
the tournament
actually there is um there's a game
today if you guys have heard of the
chess player
I'm on Hamilton he's playing I think
he's still playing unless he just lost
you checked the game it's the st. Louis
fall chest classic oh he's still playing
okay I just want to show everyone this
game does Lee chess have it in there
broadcast thanks for subbing grooving
Reuven with twitch crime appreciate that
okay me chest does not have the
broadcast so I'm gonna pull up I'm gonna
pull up chest bomb but I'll just copy
the the thing to analysis board so this
is a game which is currently live it's
between Stevens urk and Amon Hamilton
and I'm just gonna copy this go back to
me chess I'll make a new study and we'll
call this let's make it a click baby
name I'm on phase the England gambit
okay against GM Stevens
loser
Hamilton because this game might be the
first time in history that's like an
over the board game between two
grandmasters in a feed array the
tournament feature is not only in
England gambit but the Queen sacrifice
variation which is just a bit
questionable but Aman is famous for this
rickety one dish it our queen takes and
three just giving away a queen I guess
this is still along the theme of this
stream of cabin openings yeah he played
this in a rating game he played this in
Iceland though I think you played this
in Iceland Hamilton I swings England
[Music]
try this
reeked of it
hmmm searching for the game
I'm not finding it I'm pretty sure I'm
on played this in the Reykjavik Open
against like a 2100 rated player and one
rock fish doesn't like this for black
it's like plus three plus three for
white but he's still alive like the
games started about four hours ago he's
just down a queen for a couple minors it
has Queen side pawns not easy for a
white to win really not easy
huh not sure how to evaluate this and to
be honest this gambit looks stupid to me
you're not alone you're not alone so
this is a current position any more
moves updated well I played a black
played King f7 and then Queen c1 aiming
to do this
not sure what's gonna happen I'll leave
the link in the chat people want to
watch the game live anyway I'm taking
off I need to get going
thanks guys for watching I'll put this
on YouTube YouTube people hope you guys
enjoyed that I hope you're inspired I'll
probably call the video beating people
with aggressive gambits until the last
game sadly